bonsoir après marcel fontaine marcel
carton jean paul kauffmann et michel
seurat depuis hier soir il faut ajouter
à la liste des français enlevés au liban
les noms de nos amis et camarades de
travail d'antenne de philippe rochot
georges en scène aurel cornéa et
jean-louis normande 4,32 plus prise en
otage et l'on comprendra l'émotion qui
est celle de toute la rédaction
d'antenne 2 un correspondant anonyme a
revendiqué ce matin au nom de la jl
islamique l'enlèvement de l'équipe
d'antenne 2 c'était la dernière
surenchère de ce mouvement contre la
france l'enlèvement a eu lieu en fin
d'après midi hier à beyrouth voici
comment cela s'est passé avec les
explications de françois cornet
7 en quittant cette mosquée de beer et
la bête dans la banlieue sud de beyrouth
où il avait rejoint son équipe après
nous avoir expédié son reportage que
philippe rochot et cette fois compagnons
ont été prise en filature par la voiture
de leurs ravisseurs
l'équipe d'antenne 2 rejoignait son
hôtel situé sur le port il était 17
heures à beyrouth après un kilomètre et
demi à la hauteur de la cité sportive
la voiture qui les suivait et une moto
doublent leur taxi et leur barre la
route deux hommes armés de kalachnikov
monde dans le taxi et oblige le
chauffeur a continué son chemin en
changeant d'itinéraires quelques rues
plus loin le chauffeur du taxi malmené
est obligé de quitter son véhicule c'est
lui qui fera plus tard le récit de
l'enlèvement depuis aucune nouvelle de
l'équipe d'antenne 2 un confrère ayant
couvert le même reportage à la mosquée
de bir el abed est passé une dizaine de
minutes plus tard sur les lieux
je suis parti avec notre confrère à pied
dont la rue où il y avait toute la foule
qui sortait des femmes voilées et c est
heureux que philippe rochot nous doubler
il a fait signe
et apparemment n'y avait aucun problème
il est évidemment il ya beaucoup de
voitures dont on devrait savoir s'est
essuyé ou pas nous avons pris un taxi
plus loin ils ont suivi d'un étrange
appel vie environ dix minutes plus tard
et ne vont rien remarqué de particulier
aux environs de la cité sportive où il
aurait donc été doublée par une
date soul avec des hommes armés et deux
d'entre eux seraient montés dans la
voiture et donc enlever
mobilisation fait depuis la nuit
dernière le mode en eau des gones aly de
français présents à beyrouth les chaises
8 de l'équipe d'antenne 2 hier soir au
dîner ont très vite inquiété il a fallu
plus d'une heure de recherches pour
retrouver le chauffeur de taxi qui
terrorisés se cacher sitôt les détails
de l'enlèvement connu et deux
journalistes et photographes se sont
partagés les téléphones de l'hôtel
cavaliers de l' agence france-presse
pour alerter qui l'ambassade de france
qui des informateurs qu'il est
responsable des milices musulmanes ce
matin après la revendication du jihad
islamique
réunis dans la rédaction de la fp et je
vais vite ont décidé d'aller ensemble
devant des décomptes et surtout la
libération de philippe rochot et de son
équipe à moi mes yeux cette femme là le
chef spirituel des mollahs et leurs
chefs politiques se livrent à imarat
1000 ce sont eux qui présidait la
cérémonie qu'a découvert l'équipe
antenne 2 avant d'être enlevée mais
habile à la bête comme à ouzaï passion
atterri ce chiffre est fief de ces deux
responsables les portes sont restées
closes
philippe rochot et son équipe venait
tout juste de réaliser un reportage sur
le parti est ce but-là pro-iranien que
nous diffusions hier soir dans cette
même édition de 20 heures nous avons
choisi de vous leur présentez afin de
mieux comprendre le climat dans lequel
avait à travailler l'équipe d'antenne 2
voilà donc à l'atmosphère bérus vie la
guerre des nerfs dans la bataille des
otages ici les partisans de dieu célèbre
le premier anniversaire de l'attentât à
la voiture piégée qui avait fait 75
morts dans ce quartier chiite de bir el
abed au sud de beyrouth juste à côté du
domicile du cheikh fadlallah l'un des
chefs religieux les plus prestigieux du
liban c'est pour cela d'ailleurs que
onze suspects ont été exécutés
dernièrement lyall à tous les dirigeants
de ce mouvement qui prend de plus en
plus d'ampleur à beyrouth mais aucun
d'eux n'a jamais revendiqué la
responsabilité de l'enlèvement des
otages leur porte parole le cheikh
ibrahim el amine réaffirmé hier encore
il n'était pour rien dans la sphère est
le sherpa de mal à leur guide spirituel
a toujours condamné ce genre d'action
mais les hommes et les chefs de ce
mouvement demeure pourtant les seuls
interlocuteurs auprès des ravisseurs et
c'est ici dans cette mouvance ou
multiples tendances qu'il faut chercher
on comprend que la négociation choix
difficile d'autant qu'à chaque discours
il renvoie la france à ses
responsabilités et pourtant un élément
nouveau jusque là en effet ce mouvement
garder ses distances vis-à-vis de la
syrie empêchant ainsi damas de prendre
une quelconque initiative comme
intermédiaire dans l'annuaire des otages
aujourd'hui on observe un rapprochement
avec les partis musulmans libanais de
gauche c'est à dire que le hezbollah le
parti de dieu avec lui sa musique a
aujourd'hui ses entrées à damas qu'il
est accepté or cela peut permettre à la
syrie de peser sur ce parti pour
favoriser une négociation pour une
possible libération des otages français
c'est l'épreuve de force entre le jihad
islamique et le gouvernement français
les intégristes pro-iranien détiennent
maintenant huit personnes en otage pour
notre part paul nahon nous continuerons
notre travail absolument nous avons en
effet décidé d'envoyer une nouvelle
équipe d'antenne 2 à beyrouth tout
simplement pour continuer le travail
d'information commencer par philippe
rochot georges en scène aurel cornéa les
jean louis normandin c'est notre travail
notre devoir et notre honneur
l'information ne peut pas s'arrêter
c'est dans ces conditions que travailler
l'équipe d'antenne 2 c'est dans ces
mêmes conditions que travailleront
pierre serra patrice du tertre et doit
trembler qui partent ce soir pour
beyrouth philippe rochot effectué pour
antenne 2 une centaine de reportages au
liban et tout le monde là bas toutes
tendances confondues apprécié sa rigueur
et son professionnalisme nous voulons
espérer que l'équipe d'antenne 2 pourra
être libéré très rapidement les
ravisseurs n'ont ils pas affirmé ce
matin que l'équipe était simplement
appréhender et nous ne voulons pas
encore croire qu'elles soient considérés
comme otages quant à nous nous
continuerons un lassabe le mans a
demandé leur libération immédiatement et
sans condition nous avons utilisé désir
soir les canaux officiels
c'est à dire ceux du gouvernement
français mais aussi nos propres contacts
ici